i think it's also useful to focus
at times
it can be a focus for five days it can
be a focus for two weeks hi there steve
kaufman here and today i want to talk
about focus
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
uh if you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a review i do appreciate it
so my last video i spoke of the
importance of variety the brain likes
new things i've often mentioned you know
the brain likes repetition but the brain
likes novelty and so i talked about
varying the nature of your activity
varying you know the kind of content
you're dealing with in terms of subject
matter in terms of difficulty level
variety is good however
it is also important to focus
at times
uh so right now for the last i would say
four or five days i've been focusing on
this
tremendous content that my tutor sarah
from iran
has sent me for persian
it's a
podcast called epitome books dot ir
it's in persian of course
and
he has a five-part series each one about
12 to 15 minutes long about the
iranian revolution
the islamic revolution
angel
i can't remember what he calls it
but so
for the last and and what i do is this
and and it's been very very effective in
terms of upgrading my iranian and or my
persian and tomorrow i have a lesson
with sarah and we're going to talk about
uh the
1979
islamic revolution in iran and based on
all the reading and listening that i've
been doing and so so i am focusing but
i'm not going to focus it's not like you
have a textbook at school and you only
ever read the one textbook i'm doing
this for a week or two and then i'll go
on to something else but i just thought
i would review with you
for those of you who are interested how
i go about doing this so
i study in sentence mode
because it is just easier for me to
digest
the persian language written in the
arabic script if i go one sentence at a
time
unfortunately with this podcast
uh it's not time stamped so i mean ideal
scenario is it's time stamp so i can
hear the natural voice
and
see the sentence it is the case for a
lot of the content that i get especially
from youtube but with this content it's
simply not the case
another disadvantage is that
at link you know the the text to speech
service that we use doesn't have very
high quality
farsi or persian text-to-speech but it
is there it's not great it's it's the
worst of any of the languages for
whatever reason
so those are the disadvantages but the
advantages are that i deal with this one
sentence which might be 8 10 12 15 words
long
uh and then i re you know i click on the
words that i don't know or the words
that are still yellow that i'm still
still trying to learn
i review them using matching pairs which
is the best type of review because
it's more forgiving you know you see
three different words
persian with the corresponding english
you got to match them if it's wrong it
goes red otherwise it goes blue you get
through them very quickly
and then i'm testing out a new activity
that we have where that sentence then
is scrambled for me so now i have to try
to put it together again in the right
order
which again allows me to focus in on
this sentence so i'm focusing on the
sentence when i read it i'm focusing on
the words as i save them and i see a
list of these words that i've saved
i can go through them in other
activities but i prefer the matching
pairs because it's easy and fast
and then
i try to put this sentence back together
again now i do sometimes vary the order
in other words in order not to disrupt
the flow
i'll go through let's say one episode
which say 12 13 minutes long
and i won't do the reassembling of the
sentences because that takes longer
so i will go through
reading looking up words get through the
whole thing
and then circle back later on to
reassemble the sentences but the the
assembling the sentences really gets me
into the the words and how they're used
but of course i've also been working
around the house these last couple of
days
there's been an amateur golf tournament
the canadian amateur golf tournament at
our golf club so i haven't been able to
play any golf so i have more time to
either work around the house or study
and of course all the time working
around the house i'm listening so i'm
listening to the same material the
iranian or the yeah the revolution so
i'm actually learning
about the
islamic revolution and the different
factions and the pati bourgeoisie or the
land owners or the labor group or the
the muslim extremists or the leftists
and all the different factions and
groups and how they
participated in or contributed to
the revolution of 1979.
part of the confusion i'm also getting
used to the iranian years i figured out
it's 621 years
less than our western calendar so you
get used to that
so a certain amount of focus here has
enabled me to pick up a number of
political terms
get a little more familiar with the
years that the iranians use the month is
still a bit of a
stretch for me
um
and and i get this
i feel that this degree of focus and
concentration has elevated my persian in
a way
uh that it wouldn't it wouldn't have
been possible without this degree of
concentration and focus now tomorrow i
will have my lesson with my tutor and we
will talk about
these events and we'll see how i do
my hope is that my tutor will say wow
you've improved
maybe she won't maybe i'll be worse i
don't know but i just thought i would
share with you that i've been having
talked about variety
that i think it's also useful to focus
at times
it can be a focus for five days it can
be a focus for two weeks
and to stay with
one
content item
but maybe vary the way you do it so
you know i'm in sentence mode sometimes
i do the you know putting the sentence
together after each sentence sometimes i
save it up to do it later on i listen to
it another thing i did was i printed
them out on paper and so i read them on
paper which is again introducing some
variety because if i read it on paper
i'm now unable to look up the word
uh rather than doing sentence by
sentence i'm now doing the whole story
so that's introducing some variety
while i remain focused on this
bit of you know content
i should add as well that
sahara is an outstanding tutor
uh she doesn't spend a lot of time
explaining the language to me she finds
me interesting content she encourages me
she has just been an unbelievable guide
to iranian culture food history
language learning content
and as i learn things of interest to me
i don't really notice the fact
that i'm learning the language although
in fact i am learning the language so
i just thought i would share that with
you my experience of the last few days
which i intend to continue until i
really feel that i've got a good grasp
on this uh particular series uh you know
and i'll leave a link to it
uh in the description box
and i mean it is part and parcel of this
whole idea of
input-based learning so i'll leave a
couple of videos as well that that touch
on related subjects because even though
what i say sometimes seems to contradict
what i said earlier in fact it's all
part of more or less the same message
which i try to present in different ways
to see if i can
stimulate people to have
more interest and more confidence
in their language learning thanks for
listening bye for now